من راه في ليله صوت الارض اعتقد ان
الفنانه السعودي الراحل طلال مداح قد عاد
من جديد الى الحياه فالشبه الكبير بينهما
يكاد يكون متطابقا الى حد لا يصدق عيسى
التركي الرجل الذي اصبح حديث العالم
العربي على مواقع التواصل عقب ظهورها على
مسرح الفنان محمد عبده في ليله صوت الارض
بسبب الشبه الكبير بينه وبين الفنان
الراحل طلال مداح وفي الليله التاريخيه
لتكريم الفنان السعودي الراحل كان لابد من
لفته تبقى في الذاكره هذه اللفته التي
كانت من خلال حضور رائع للكثير من
الفنانين ومحبي صاحب الحنجره الذهبيه
الجميع دون استثناء عاش لحظات دهشه بسبب
الشبه الذي لفت نظرهم بين التركي ومداح
واليوم في صباح العربيه سنكون عن قرب مع
الشبيه الذي اعاد صوره طلال مداح للحضور
بين الجمل
اول شيء بدنا نعرف متى اكتشفت هذا الشبه
الكبير بينك وبين الراحل طلال
ما عندي يعني علم بشبه هذا جت فتره من
الفترات تقريبا قبل 17 سنه او 18 سنه
تقريبا
كل ما اجي اخرج في اي محفل ولا في يعني
مناسبه متعلقه بالاصحاب الناس يعني تبدا
ايش تتقرب لي وتتصور معايا انت شبهك
فما كنت يعني كنت متوقع انه هذا الشبح
حيكون بالحجم هذا يعني
طيب استاذ عيسى تمنيت انه يكون عندك صوت
جميل قريب لصوت الراحل المبدع طلال مداح
ومثلا قد تمثل دور من اعماله اعمال
مستقبليه مثلا والله صوت طلال مداح اجمع
عليه الجميع يعني على اساس انه كان موهبه
ومن الله سبحانه وتعالى للفنان الكبير
رحمه الله عليه كان يجذب قلوب الناس كثيرا
يعني كنت الواحد كان يتمنى بصراحه انه
يكون عنده صوت صوت طالع المداح
هذه طبعا مو بيدي الواحد يعني طيب سيدي
عيسى انتشر لك بقوه جدا فيديو وانت تتحدث
مع ابنه الرحم طلال مداح شو اللي دار
بينكم وكيف كان شعورها بس شافتك والله
ابنه الفنان طلال مدح نغم اصرت على
مقابلتي بحيث كنت اتحاشى انا على اساس
الموقف اللي صار خفت
مؤثر بيني وبينك فصرت ولما قابلتني انصدمت
وانبهرت من الشبه اللي بيني وبين والدها
يعني طيب لدرجه انها قالت نسخه يعني
بس انا كمان
بدي حا
ولت طفات لتاكد وتزيد هذا الشبح يعني هل
النظارات
اللي انت حاطتهم كانت مقصوده انه تكون
شبيهه بالتي كان يستعملها الراحل طلال
مداح لا والله بالعكس
اطارات ثانيه تختلف
يعني
لو ارد عليك دور في فيلم يحكي عن الراحل
طلال مداح توافق انك اتمثل
يقبل الكلام هذا
[موسيقى]